dolphins are some of the oceans most
iconic creatures but that's not the only
place where these graceful mammals live
less famous than their ocean
counterparts river dolphins inhabit some
of the world's mightiest rivers
including the Ganges the Mekong the
Yangtze and the Amazon
unfortunately the pressures of boat
traffic dam building fishing and
pollution have taken their toll on many
of these freshwater dolphin populations
most river dolphins are endangered and
in 2006 China's Yangtze River Dolphin
was declared functionally extinct in the
wild but in one part of the world there
is a glimmer of hope for river dolphins
the Amazon here in the Amazon you can
find two different species of dolphins
one is the Amazon River dolphins and the
other dove in the satalia is one of the
smallest dolphin in the world colombian
biologists Fernando Trujillo is one of
the world's foremost river dolphin
experts for years I have been working
with a river dolphins almost 20 years
but so far we don't know the numbers and
we are talking with governments to say
you need to protect the river dolphins
and they always ask how many dolphins
have
now with the support of World Wildlife
Fund and other conservation
organizations Fernando is searching for
an answer to that question embarking on
the first ever census South America's
River Dolphin population so far we have
count dolphins in the river Orinoco in
Venezuela in the river Mehta in Colombia
and in number of tributaries of the
Amazon in Peru and Ecuador the numbers
from some areas aren't encouraging like
in Venezuela's Orinoco River I'm a
little concerned with their in Oakland
because the numbers of dolphin we have
found in their inoko are relatively low
comparing with the Amazon where in some
countries like Peru we found a very
healthy populations of river dolphins
with numbers above 2000 animals for each
species but in the Orinoco we have found
something like thousand animals and we
are very concerned he and his team are
slowly and systematically working their
way through the Dolphins range and
Counting every dolphin they see for each
sighting researchers use GPS data to log
the Dolphins location and any other
useful information
along the way signs of yet another
threat to the river dolphins logging
they bring the loves here the wood and
they could in pieces and sent to Iquitos
another big cities
besides logging accidental capture and
killing by fishermen and pollution are
also putting the squeeze on South
America's dolphins but despite these
threats the team continues to spot
dolphin
after dolphin after dolphin at one known
dolphin hangout Fernando pauses to
photograph the animals so he can
identify them later
he hopes to spots unfamiliar flippers we
have a catalogue with about 176
identified animals here each time we try
to take pictures and see the natural
history of each one of these animals
back on the big boat the results for
this stretch of the Amazon are promising
I'm quite happy so far we have seen more
than 600 dolphins in a relatively small
area about 200 of 3 300 kilometers so I
can see the densities of dolphins are in
good conditions here as part of his
mission
Fernando works to educate the people who
live along the rivers about the
importance of caring for the dolphins in
their habitat favorite dolphins are
disappearing so we can stop this process
but we need to be very creative and we
need to work with fishermen we need to
work with the government we need to work
with children need to work together for
this it's a long road but a promising
one with dedicated scientists like
Fernando on their side the river
dolphins of the Amazon stand a fighting
chance for survival
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium